[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir europe mon le seul à
tout de suite pas trop tu es bien pressé
nounours mes amis m'attendent ce qu'ils
vont être contents hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop on vous aussi les enfants vous
allez être contents car nous nous fera
vous raconter une jolie histoire
bonsoir les petits c'est quelle histoire
que tu n'auras pas une histoire d'une
petite fille que vous aimez beaucoup
devinez filippi oui à la côtoient et
commence là je me pose aussi la cote
philippines se leva de très bonne heure
elle prit son tambour et
se mit à jouer si fort qu'elle réveille
à toute la maison
[Rires]
le lapin blanc qui avaient dormi dans la
chambre de la petite fille se leva aussi
timidité midi tibi dit j'ai faim moi
aussi répondit la petite fille ronde
charmante annick taquine et gentille le
petit déjeuner sentait bon le papa la
maman philippines et le lapin blanc
sacyr à table
le papa avait une passe de café la maman
une tasse de thé philippine avait un bol
de lait le lap à blanc une assiette
pleine de carottes
ils mangèrent tous avec bon appétit à
l'exception du lapin blanc
quichotte à ces carottes ont l'air
la maman lui apporta alors un magnifique
souffleur mais lille shota le chou fleur
en l'air
alors le papa lui donna une belle salade
verte et le lapin blanc goethe à la
salade en l'air
mais lorsque philippines pause a devant
lui un pot de confiture de frein
tibi dibi dibi dit le lapin blanc se
jeta dessus hennebont chatou à celui là
alors qu'il est pour moi et pour
remercier la petite fille qui était
devenu son ami il lui donna un gentil
baiser de lapin oui de nouveaux billets
d'apporter la suite je n'ai pas oublié
j'ai fait exprès je vous la raconterai
une autre fois quand vous aurait été
sage mais tu nous donnes les livres oui
je vous le donne
à lyon allons les enfants rient
bonne nuit les petits
la
gta renner
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
oui
dibi dibi début détient voici le lapin
blanc mais non c'est moi un patron
nounours allons en route gros farceur
bonne nuit les enfants bonne nuit les
enfants andres assez bien fort vos
parents embrasse bien fort vos parents
et faites de beaux rêves tu veux te pour
oh
[Musique]